ayúdame a graficar la siguiente función
y a encontrar su inversa la función sf
de x igual a 4 x + 2 pero que es la
inversa vamos a averiguarlo poco a poco
primero puedes ver que nuestra función
está acompañada de esta tabla en la
primera columna tenemos equis y cuatro
valores luego un espacio en blanco y
después fx entonces necesitamos
completar este espacio
sustituyendo nuestra función para
encontrar fx y poder graficar los datos
empecemos con el primer valor que es 4
al sustituir 4 nuestra función obtenemos
que 4x4 2 es igual a 18 el siguiente
valores 3 4 por tres más dos nos da 14
al sustituir menos 2 tenemos 4 x menos 2
más 2 igual a menos 6 y por último 4 por
menos 5 2 y el resultado es menos 18
excelente lo que haremos ahora es
agregar una columna del lado derecho de
fx y ahí colocaremos los datos que
acabamos de encontrar junto con los
valores de x estos dos se convertirán en
las coordenadas que vamos a graficar
entonces el primero es x 4 y fx 18 luego
en x 3 y nf x 14 para el siguiente en x
menos 2 y nf x menos 6 el último es en x
menos 5 y nf x menos 18 muy bien tomemos
la primera coordenada para marcarla en
nuestro plano cartesiano 4,18
pero antes de cualquier cosa es
importante que sepas que en el plano el
eje que probablemente antes
identificadas como y ahora los
llamaremos fx y x seguirá siendo x
empecemos en x buscamos 4 y nf x
y los marcamos
ahora identifiquemos la coordenada 314
muy bien aquí está la coordenada menos 2
menos 6 está aquí y la marcamos sólo nos
falta menos 5 menos 18 la buscamos en el
plano y listo
por último unimos los puntos justo así
perfecto ahora vamos a encontrar la
inversa de esta función así que se
invierte exactamente la representación
producida por la función f pero primero
debemos descubrir si nuestra función
tiene inversa ya que no todas tienen
para eso despejamos nuestra función
original es decir f x es igual a 4 x + 2
si logramos despejar la quiere decir que
esta función tiene inversa empecemos f x
es igual a 4 x + 2 el más 2 está sumando
por lo que pasa de este lado restando y
tenemos f x menos 2 es igual a 4x
4x está multiplicando así que al
despejar lo pasa dividiendo y obtenemos
fx menos dos entre cuatro es igual a
equis sólo nos queda invertir fx por
equis para que obtengamos x2 entre 4 es
igual a fx menos uno que es lo mismo que
fx menos uno igual a equis menos dos
entre cuatro
es muy importante que sepas que el -1 de
efe únicamente se refiere a la inversa
de la función y no al exponente menos 1
por lo que nada más se utiliza como
notación de la función inversa super
logramos despejar nuestra función eso
quiere decir que si tiene inversa lo
siguiente es hacer lo mismo que con la
función original sustituir en la fórmula
inversa los valores que tenemos en la
tabla para encontrar efe - 1 de x
el primer valor es 4 al sustituirlo
queda de la siguiente manera 4
2 entre 4 es igual a 2 cuartos y su
equivalente es un medio
el siguiente valor en la tabla es 332
entre 4 es igual a un cuarto después
menos 2 - 2 - 2 entre 4 es igual a menos
4 cuartos y su equivalente es menos 1
entero
y el último valor de la tabla menos
cinco menos 52 entre 4 es igual a menos
7 cuartos en la última columna
establecemos las coordenadas la primera
es 41 medio después 3,1 cuarto seguimos
con menos dos coma menos uno y menos 5,7
cuartos vamos súper bien sólo nos queda
graficar las en el plano identificamos
la coordenada 4,1 medio es ésta de aquí
luego 3,1 cuarto falta menos dos menos
uno y menos cinco menos siete cuartos es
justo una rayita antes del dos en el
plano fx
one lo único que falta es unir los
puntos que acabamos de identificar para
ver cómo se forma nuestra gráfica
excelente encontramos la inversa de la
función éste fue sólo un ejemplo pero
recuerda que si puedes despejar una
función original ésta tendrá su inversa